avec votre permission je voudrais
revenir sur le propos de paul sujet à
l'instant je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose dans la conception du sacrement de
l'ordre qui me paraît à revoir je crois
que le ministère aura
en grand grande crise parce qu'il a été
sacralisé c'est le seul sacrement dont
on dit dans le code de droit canon qu'il
ait de droit divin et là on ne peut pas
empêcher que c'est quelque chose qui
favorisent les abus quand vous êtes
investi d'une mission à un titre divin
et bien la personne qui est en face de
vous n'a pas la faculté de vous résistez
vous êtes avec des glissements
successifs vous êtes dieu donc là il ya
très certainement quelque chose à revoir
et c'est le code milles 8 du code de
droit canon 1008 du code de droit
canonique je pense que il ya vraiment un
travail profond à faire là-dessus le
ministère ordonné doit être revue je
vais pas dire à la baisse parce que pour
moi c'est un gain quand on gagne en
humanité
mais on doit le désacraliser parce que
c'est une charge trop lourde à porter
pour lui et pour son entourage ça ça me
paraît vraiment important de travailler
là-dessus mais je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit d'actualité
[Musique]